bonsoir.
- Bonsoir, M. Roy.s s s s s s s.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ,
ministre de la Santé, Québec
- Bien, écoutez, on a fait aussx
de bord dans les derniers jours,
parce que l'indicateur dont vous
parlez, c'est pas qu'il n'estboe
complété par d'autres. Preno
le cas de l'Hôpital juif.
Oui, on a un taux d'occuqui este
des civières qui soupupupupées,
mais il faut regarder aussi
le temps de traite
prend. Les gens, par exemple,
est-ce qu'ils enenenent 4 heures
ou 11 heures ou 18 heures?
Alors l'Hô
notre meilleur exemple,
parce que,enenenen ce moment,
ils ont des gros taux
d'occu
en raison des enfants, mais
t t t t temps, ils réussissent
à avoir des temps d'attente
très raisonnables., , , , , c'ea
les meilleures pratiques
est en train de regarderpour am,
entre autres, de l'Hôpital
urgences à travers le Québec
pour mieux passait à travers
cette crise-là.
que vous avez en tête pour
voir quand même ces chiffres
la diminuent.
ouvrir, il y a différentes
mesures que vous aviez annoncé
il y a deux semaines.
- Est-ce que... jusqu'à Noël,
on doit vivre avec des taux
qui seront quand même
- Bon, on va continuer à vivre
avec des taux élevés, comme
par exemple le taux d'occupation
ça prend un certain temps.
Mais déjà, on a vu
des améliorations depuis la...le
la mise en place des cellules,
mais on a commencé.
Prenons par exemple une façonrg,
c'est de s'assurer que nos lits
à l'étage sont libérés
plus rapidement pour queuiuiuius
puissent monter à l'étage
et libérer les urgences.
On a vu des améliorationsnenenes
dans le détail de nos
de bord, mais maintenant,
les Québécois sontd'aller voir .
Moi, j'essaye eseseseseseses
encourageants que plusieurs
des choses f
Par exemple, là, on avait promis
deux cliniques, ce qu'on appsus.
La bonne nouvelle que j'ai
c'est qu'on m'a dit : on va
être capable d'en faiororororore
nouvelle. Ça va c
- Avec un numéro de téléphone?
- Non, je vous
sur place.
- Non, non,
je veux dire, l'interface
pour le
vous avez voulu simplifier
ça a
- Aussi, merci de le rappeler,
pa
peut-être un peu compliqué de
ueueueueueueueuel numéro appele.
On a changé ça, on a vu
à notre goût. Là maintenant,nsn.
Je le répète, si, par exemple
pour les enfants 0 à 17 ans,vov.
Et là, si vous êtes sur
dans les prochaines heures,
ça va être en Montérégie,
Lanaudière, etc., les gens
rendez-vous pour vous dans
une clinique. Donc, il y a
vraiment des améliorations
mises en place.
- Bien, on le souhaite et on va
suivre ça évidemment avec vous.
le réseau est sous pression,
c'est une évidence,
et vous dîtes : le masque
des visites à l'urgence, en tout
cas, on prend pas de chance.
Et là, vous recommandez queicics
fermés... bon, transports
en commun, il va sans dire,
théâtre...s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,
enfin, bref. Les bibliothèques.
Vous recommandez fortement
le port du masque. q q q q q q ,
M. Roy, on a dit : des lieux
publics qui sont achalandés.
Et je vous donne l'exemp
- Centre d'achat?
- Vous a
Prenez mon exemple :
vous aururururururururururant,
vous êtes deux personnes
et
à trois tables de vous,
o o o o o o o o o obligation-l.
On se fie beaucoup au jugement
aller dans un endroit public,tr,
c'est la proximité qui est
un élément important à tenir
en compte. Donc, on a décidé s .
Après trois ans de pandémie,
je pense que la plupart
des Québécois savent un peu
comment se comporter.
Et donc, cette espèce
de comportement citoyen-là,
on va l'expliquer, mais je pense
que les gens comprennent
qu'il faut être prudent.
- Avez-vous jonglé,
Monsieur le ministre, avec...
parce que vous venez de le dire,
vous avez employé le mot
"il n'y a pas d'obligation
dans un restaurant où on est
très loin", en voulant dire :
il y aurait une obligation
si on est dans un centre d'achat
tout collés, mais il n'y aura
pas d'obligation.
Avez-vous jonglé avec l'idée
de l'obliger quand même?
- Non. C'est évident
qu'on est passé à autre chose.
Et je le répète, M. Roy :
on a été longtemps dans
un concept d'obligation
pour une foule de raisons,
rappelez-vous. Il n'y avait pas
de vaccinations et tout ça.
Mais les gens, maintenant,
peuvent se faire vacciner.
Les gens peuvent...
Et je pense que, quand
on regarde l'ensem
des mesures sanitaires,
on parle comme par exemple
le masque, je pense que
ce sont ces me
vont faire que les gens avec
leurs habitudes, je le répète,
des dernières années,
sont
le bon jugement et on se fie
à ce comportement citoyen-là
qui devrait être exemplaire.
p p p p p p p p p p p p passé,
ces obligations-là.
- Voilà.
- Un mot avant de vous laisserme
rappel, on les appelle comme ça,
maintenant, on ne les compte
plus, de un à quatre à à cinq...
- Deuxième dose de rappel,
on est en retard, là.
C'est petit, mais on peutoioioi.
On est parmi... L'Alberta
est un tout petit peu
en dessous de nous.
Ça va moins vite au Québec.
Là, vous avez fait une pub
d'ailleurs avec le père Noël
et le temps des Fêtes arrive.
C'est... Qu'est-ce vous dite
aux gens? Qu'est-ce que la santé
publique dit aux gens? "Allez-y,
même si vous êtes en santé"?
- Bien, on dit deux choses.
Ce qui est important,
c'est de respecter le plus
possible délai de cinq mois.
Si ça fait plus que cinq mois
que vous avez reçus
votre deuxième dose de rappel,
et je dirais particulièrement
avant les Fêtes, où il va
y avoir plus de contacts,
il faut aller chercher
cette dose de rappel-là.
Moi, le chiffre que je regarde,
c'est pas uniquement à l'échelle
du Québec, les chiffres
que vous venez de cite
pour les catégories d'âge des
personnes qui sont plus âgées.
Vous savez, au-dessus de 80 ans,
le pourcentage e
au-dessus de 60 %, et ça, c'est
sans compter que des personnes
dans ça qui ont peut-être
fait la CO
une protection additionnelle.
Donc, je le regarde
par catégorie d'âge, parce que
c'
c'est protéger nos gens
les plus vulnérables.
- Mais le mot d'ordre, c'est :